Kayla
boundaries because I mean that's kind of
what we're talking about is boundaries
yeah when it comes to I can't take a gal
series that has guy friends so let's say
it's a different conversation and he
says Kayla I dig your Vibe yes you know
we're talking about marriage you know
all that kind of good stuff yeah I can't
take a girl seriously that's posting
sexy provocative selfies on Instagram I
can't have a girlfriend doing that yeah
is that is that the same as the guy
friends or is that a conversation you'd
sit down and be like yeah you know what
probably right
uh
uh for me because I again I was married
I didn't post anything for eight years
and it
I now videotape and take pictures of
everything including me going to the
pool so if it's considered a sexy thing
when I work hard for my body that's it's
not my problem who considers it sexy it
like I'm confident I like why do you do
it though like if you are confident then
then why do you do it and put it out to
the public
because I was pregnant once and I didn't
look good and I like to know I my like
even my girlfriends comment on it and
they're like oh you look so good you
know you put in a lot of work it's it's
complimenting people who like I do it if
I feel like someone deserves a
compliment and it's nice to hear things
you don't know if they just don't hear
anything so all of them so all the
compliments that I'm reading here on one
of your posts is uh guy guy guy guy I
know which one you're probably looking
at Queen of something guy guy so it's
all guys that are complimenting you here
so it's so it's validation coming from
Men
but if you have a guy in your life that
says I want to make you part of my life
and invite you into it and put a ring on
your fingers and babies in you and he
says look this is a boundary for me I
can't have somebody that I'm serious
about posting sexy provocative selfies
on like it's got nothing to do with your
business like it if you're a fitness
model and you're selling bang energy
drinks or whatever then then I would get
it but you're in real estate right like
why do you need to post pictures of
yourself almost naked
I have a separate separate page for my
for graywood homes
so anybody can see it like I don't
follow you and I can right well I
well I'll let myself I don't
I don't do anything for anybody except
for myself okay yeah so so it's about
your central point
I post whatever I want and if I was to
be with someone if I was to be with
someone and they had a problem with men
complimenting me there's an issue and
it's not with me well and it could be
real like a man complimenting you at the
grocery store when you're checking out
says hey you know I like your eyes sort
of thing is different from you taking a
provocative selfie in a mirror and
posting it on the gram for everybody to
see and comments on would you agree
and we're probably just gonna have to
agree to disagree I think everybody's
different and I know plenty of men who
would not have a problem with it
um I want to hear from the other ladies
on you know the same sort of question
right I mean
um if you're with a guy and you're
talking something long-term and he said
hey look you know I dig your Vibe too
but if I were to take you seriously like
I really can't
deal with you if you're going to be
posting sexy provocative photographs
here online
how would you handle that
well you know let's go to Ashley first
because I know that you do only fans so
would you give up your livelihood for a
guy basically I guess is the question
um I've been asked actually
um a few times if I would quit belief
that's what I'm doing or to date them
and uh
I said no
uh that I wouldn't take them I would
want someone that's okay with it
just because it's what I've chosen to do
you know I can't say how long I'll be
gonna pay really well for you like how
does it I'm not sure what the model is
because I'm not a gal dude unless I live
off of
more than enough to live off of more
than enough yeah okay so it sounds like
you do pretty well so I mean what if the
guy made loads of money said you know I
just want to take care of you and you
know put babies in you you know make my
house a home and that sort of thing like
would you give it up then if you really
wanted me to like absolutely take care
of everything
I would
I would probably choose a different job
like if it was just the pictures that
bothered him and if he was financially
responsible for everything I would be
like okay I'll do it but I still want to
have enough money for myself in case
like something were to happen and fall
through
okay so you need your own like Financial
backup plan like you have your own uh
Nest Egg but you would
I guess comply because he's a high value
guy and he can take care of you in that
sense
yeah okay all right
um Sophie
I haven't seen your Instagram yet but
there's nothing on there actually tell
me like what's your story you know when
it comes to that sort of conversation
like what are your thoughts on that no I
definitely think it's you know if you
put yourself out there
you know
expecting compliments you know you're
gonna get you know you put you post on
social media you know you're gonna get
people commenting on there saying oh you
look good you know whatever but you're
setting yourself up for that so it's
like
you know it's not like you're asking for
it but you know it's gonna happen you
know you're gonna get these people these
guys commenting I mean you know your
Instagram whatever you know what's gonna
happen so it's like you're kind of
setting yourself up for that so if you
were in a relationship and I you know
you post something or if I were to post
something knowing
think well I'm gonna get people
commenting under this and it's gonna
hurt him I want to do it I flat out when
I do knowing that he's going to read
this he's going to see I put that on
there
knowing these people are going to
comment and he's going to read it and he
you know that's gonna hurt that's just
it's not it's not fair
Alexander what's your take on that
what was the going back to what was the
original question uh the other question
was you're you're in a relationship
you've had the Where Do We Stand talk I
want to claim you and I want to share
you I want to be your girlfriend blah
blah blah and then he comes back and
says well I dig your Vibe too but your
Instagram's covered in half naked photos
of you and I can't take a gal seriously
that does that
I would agree with them
because because
would you just stop taking the
photographs would you make it private
like what would your strategy be at that
point well my Instagram's private anyway
um and you control your audience I think
that you know when you're first getting
into a relationship with somebody you
know to get a glimpse into their world
the easiest way is social media who are
you following how many followers do you
have for me I don't I don't need to see
that you have 14
000 you know followers unless like your
content is more aligned with the
motivational and trying to help people
you know having fourteen thousand
followers and being a bikini model is
great but who's your audience and at the
end of the day your audience should be
that significant other and how they feel
and it's the small sacrifices and having
the conversation is what is provocative
to you is posting in a bikini with
friends is that provocative for you for
you or is you know posting your your
butt straight on the internet
provocative
you know but people
the question is interesting because I
mean there's a there's a divide on that
question when you ask it and it seems
like most women today are like well why
are you insecure why are you trying to
be controlling I would just move on sort
of thing but
I think women fail to recognize the like
the way that I describe this man again I
said top shelf he's got his stuff
together he's compelling you've you've
asked to be with him you know you've
said where do we stand I want to claim
you I don't want to share you it's rare
for women to do that like women only
choose men like that when they're really
high value guys you know they tick off
your boxes and then he just says well I
have a boundary
and I don't I don't cross that boundary
like this is a firm boundary and you say
well pound sand buddy I'll just find
somebody else right like there's a large
contingent of the female dating
demographic right now that would say get
lost
okay
what do you guys say to that it goes
back to the boundary you hit it right on
the head you know women and men both
have you know lists of non-negotiables
per se if that was on your list to the
at the beginning and I knew that then
you can decide ahead of time is what
what do I want it's not something that I
would encourage guys to put on the table
at the beginning like I deal with guys a
lot in this realm and a lot of like most
men generally speaking I think want to
be in a relationship like the last guy
on my unplugged Alpha podcast he was on
for like 90 minutes the dude's an insult
he just wants a girlfriend he doesn't
even want to date multiple women
simultaneously to let the cream rise to
the top he doesn't he doesn't want to go
to the gym to get a girlfriend he wants
to remain at 110 pounds right but he
wants a girlfriend so guys have a strong
desire I think for intimacy with the
opposite sex bottom line I mean that's
why we're here
men are here to scatter seed women are
here to have babies like we're not here
to build skyscrapers and Roads and cars
and charge our [__] and all that stuff
like this is the main reason why why
we're here right I think it's a fair
assessment
so it's like
you know if you've you know if you come
across somebody that's that valuable or
potentially that valuable that that you
lean into them and say Hey I want to be
with you I've I have chosen you I've
abandoned my other options and I I just
dig your Vibe and he says well I have a
boundary and it's like a lot of women
today they're just like nah
you're insecure but I think it would be
a different story if you actually had
him sitting across from you I I
truthfully believe and and I think all
women inclusive of Kayla would even
contemplate this very very strongly if
there was a guy sitting across from you
that was like a 10 out of 10 and ticked
off all the boxes and he said that you
would actually probably think about it
and and think to yourself well is this
is the attention and validation of men
that I don't really care about that
let's be honest aren't ever going to be
a part of my future long term anyway
worth keeping around to abandon
this guy Adonis
go ahead
sorry you put up your hand you can just
talk
I didn't know how it worked um I mean my
thing is
Instagram he knew how I was so for him
to come into my life and then be like
you know what I don't like the way that
you post things I don't actually post
things for like
to get other men to date me right no but
you said but I mean like you said like
you do it because you because you're
proud of your body and you want to show
off and you want the acknowledgment from
the world that it exists in this state
it's very it's very common in gym
culture for you to post your body or
like there's plenty of accounts that
like I said earlier I mean look I know
men with shirtless yeah I know fitness
models that are all about it because
they promote anyone who drinks and
supplements and stuff like that right
like yeah you kind of have to be about
that but I mean you're in real estate
right but I'm in
sphere does not reflect
someone does that for a career doesn't
mean they're the only ones allowed to
post that post their work post their
bodies that when they go to the gym oh
like oh only them they're the only ones
because they do it for it no like we
work hard too I'm in there hip thrusting
300 pounds right now if I want to take a
video of me walking in the sand because
my butt used to be flat I will because I
worked hard for my butt it's not for me
to be like oh like everybody look it's
like I'm not sitting here for for a man
to come over to my house right I think
it's good for so let me rephrase the
question in a slightly different way
maybe maybe table it you know for
everybody this way
um do you think it's good for a
relationship
to have you doing something like that to
have yourself you know like showing
yourself off to others
I actually dated a guy
um and he said something about how he
actually likes it because it kind of
lets you know that you're a wanted woman
right like other men would like to have
you but knowing me where's this guy
today how come you're not with him
um we just
it's again like things don't work out
two different people
exam they're like the best ex-girlfriend
they've ever had just because I'm very
understanding I'm not like a I'm not
like a crazy ex or something like that
it's just people don't work out and oh
well like move on you know
um but he said that his opinion on it is
like it shows that other men want you
but they can't have you and I'm a very
monogamous monogamous woman and loyal
woman I've never cheated on anybody and
to know that that girl is like yours and
only yours he was all about it it he
loved it don't you think don't you think
potentially by leaving your Instagram
open
allowing men to DM and comment and
things like that that's not somehow
cracking the door and leaving it open to
other men in his eyes
I don't respond to their messages and he
would know that
right but I mean right it's the fact
that the Thirsty beta males that are
messaging you though but if a guy with a
blue check mark who's happened to be a
Hollywood actor like Chris Hemsworth
messages you
better fit you ignore him
like you
know for me it probably
exercise right if there was someone who
was a better fit for you and we sat down
we had a discussion about it cool go for
it I don't want to be the person that
you're stuck with for 60 years I've had
this conversation at when you're married
oh yeah yeah I'm proud of that you're
proud of that aren't you
be like oh I wasn't trying
to check we're all human our bodies work
a certain way and to sit there and be
like no absolutely not I'm not I'm just
not the person to do that right I'm not
gonna Force someone who's shame
there's a I think there's a big
difference between checking someone out
and saying that person's attractive
versus
is this person a better fit I mean
that's not something you can essentially
identify with one glance
um I I think the Crux of it is this
there's guys out there myself included
that
um you know if a woman is advertising
herself and her Instagram is open and
she's got good looking pictures of
herself and she's single by all means go
for it you know do your thing and so but
if a guy says okay I'm gonna claim you
you're my woman I'm Your Man
it's just it's essentially like I've
bought a car from a dealership but the
the first sales sign is still on the car
so it's like if if you're with me and
and we're together
you know why why are you continuing to
act in the same way you were acting when
you were single when we're together why
is there no sort of the for sale sign is
still out there it's still sort of
advertising yourself as available to
other men in the world even if it's just
by having DMS or comments open in in
that attention even because guys will
hold on to the most tiny sliver of hope
that you can possibly imagine I mean I
had a conversation with somebody's about
this last night guys will stay in the
friend zone for decades if they think
there's even a small chance that one day
they'll get that chance or you'll get
drunk enough at a death metal concert
that you guys end up making out and then
who knows
so yeah it's ultimately how guys kind of
look at it it looks like you're still
sort of acting single even though you're
in a relationship
right
that phone's probably about to die I
would have to run upstairs without a
charger so if it does it's not that I
left
um I want to point something out is that
I am single but again I'm not the type
to hook up with people so I wouldn't
really change the way that I am inside
of a relationship compared to who I am
as a person right now so it's not like I
would but it's about the what you're
putting out there though that's what I'm
trying to get at and not to cut you off
but it's about what you're communicating
like it's I mean it's about what you're
communicating what you're putting out
into the world it's not talking about
you specifically I'm talking about women
in general yeah
so I think that's what because when guys
see that it's you know leaving an
Instagram open leaving DMS open is an
invitation there she goes that's okay
she'll come back yeah just grab that
charger and come back then
um so I don't know what do you ladies
think of all that
I'm gonna try man just say what you got
to say
people aren't maybe as one-dimensional
as cars are
I feel like the analogy in my opinion
isn't
maybe the best
I feel like
um and maybe it's just because of what I
do for work that I might be a little bit
biased
but how many
um adonises are out there just waiting
for every girl that would be considered
high value
there's you know that's sort of where I
see it is like there's not that many
guys that are out there
I feel like it's unrealistic for
everyone to think that way if that makes
sense I'm not sure
so you think there's like there's not an
abundance of men that are worth
putting your Instagram on private or
quitting your only fans for is what
you're saying a little bit yeah like
sort of going back to like if I did meet
someone like that who was willing to
take care of me whatever I would
probably change but there's not a lot of
guys out there or women out there that
can do that but don't you think that
kind of works against you in a way so if
the pool of men that are at that level
is already small yeah why not do what's
in your best possible interest to
increase your odds as much as possible
to potentially lock one of those guys
down
um because I have to take care of myself
first you know and uh
sort of going into the reason why I do
only fans is because I have a certain
medical conditions that I you know
sort of limit me to being at my house a
lot and uh you know it was sort of
what landed in my lap uh and I don't
think like
holding that off for the prospect of
like an imaginary man that's like my
princess I'm not an imaginary man it's
an actual man that's saying you know
look you've you know you've asked me to
be monogamous you and you want to claim
me and you don't want me to see anybody
else so I have a request for you yeah
and I I don't take women seriously that
post provocative photographs online I
said I would I would change for him but
I'm saying in the current state right
now
yeah because you need it I got it okay
yeah I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out